nasa probably would have never launched
90 year old will shatner they would have
seen it as a stunt
and you look at the media attention that
got
uh so there's a certain sort of cultural
well you know nasa probably shouldn't
have launched
william shatner
you know i mean would you want your tax
dollars going to that
[Music]
this is star talk
cosmic queries edition
always popular with our audience and
today we're going to talk about the
future
of space
public versus private space missions
everybody's thinking and talking about
this subject chuck
have you been in any conversation where
they heard you were related to star talk
and this did not come up
um
yes
[Laughter]
no people are very much i mean it's
maybe that's a good thing though that's
the one good thing about it it's a buzz
yeah what no matter where people land in
the issues
it's a topic of conversation which is
something we haven't really been talking
about space lately i mean right there
was you know there's been these lulls in
it well we've got on the show today
someone who is perhaps the most
pedigreed person
in the world to talk on this subject oh
my gosh
an old friend and co-worker lori garver
lori welcome to star talk thank you it
is wonderful to be here uh and you have
a you know an arm's length resume and
every
item on that resume is space related the
one we have here just because we're
being lazy is that your former deputy
administrator to nasa appointed by obama
so the deputy administrator is the
second highest ranking person
at nasa if i remember the the the org
chart
and you're the recent author of escaping
gravity
my quest to transform nasa
and launch a new space agency i see what
you did there with the yeah
now uh disclosure here i actually
blurbed the book
okay so if you look somewhere on the
cover or inside uh so i'm gonna read you
my blurb so here it is
former nasa official lori garver offers
a front row seat
to the decades-long struggle within and
among space bureaucrats and space
billionaires bring popcorn as you bear
witness to an untold slice of space
history neil degrasse tyson
american museum of natural history
because that i've read that book it was
like where's the popcorn oh my gosh
oh my gosh so laurie
laurie
you've you've you've done tours of duty
in government in industry it you've you
you've seen sides of this more sides of
this
of this multi-dimensional space than
most people have
how do you
does this make enemies with everybody or
friends with everybody like did the
bureaucrats see you as a industry person
to the industry people seriously
bureaucrat do the academics see you as a
kiss up to the who
do you have any friends at all left
yeah you know i have a dog and i live in
washington so that's probably that's one
friend you got one friend okay
the dog is proud of you every day no
matter what you did that day yes exactly
be who your dog thinks you are yes
that's my motto um you you nailed it
i've got
people who
see
what from their corner view my
perspective as not quite in their corner
because i think my view and the point of
of the book thank you for your blurb and
introduction is that i i brought a
different perspective to my two tours at
nasa i've been there over 10 years twice
for about five years each
ran the policy office in the clinton
administration
in the 90s and
we have always been going to be on this
path you know of
launching a new space age uh people been
talking about it for decades it didn't
just start with elon musk and jeff bezos
but because of them we are talking about
it more and for a lot of reasons that
i'm sure we will talk about today we
have um a lot of people questioning why
we're doing it a certain way is this the
best way
why isn't it just nasa anymore
why aren't we back on the moon and why
aren't we on mars
many questions
plus if you go if you go
private sort of independent space
industry the huge space industrial
complex
probably feels threatened at some level
is that a fair comment that's the real
rub i think is that aerospace managed to
late 50s early 60s
transform their
uh
the equipment and weapons they used into
civil space programs and it's those very
contractors who have been working for
nasa contracting with the space agency
ever since and doing wonderful things
but doing it on contract where you got
paid the usual
large amount whether you delivered or
not year after year and they didn't want
to let that go obviously the glamour of
launching astronauts um
is a wonderful thing for them especially
because they were also getting billions
to do it if you calculate about
350 billion dollars that we've spent on
human space flight since apollo we've
launched about 350 people
so
they've been getting a lot of money to
launch astronauts and to
be able to market themselves as that
kind of company and not just a weapons
building company so they did not wait we
just wanted to do this wait wait wait i
know stop yeah we just you just slipped
i'm not an astrophysicist but that math
kind of sounds like a billion dollars a
person yeah i i don't just slide by that
lori so we're talking nearly a billion
dollars if you if you am if you average
that out a billion dollars per human
being launched into space since apollo
that nasa has done that has nothing to
do with these private
rights but that's a number just like
just a dangling there in front of us
it's in the book it's hard to
you know just like with the shuttle we
can say oh there's marginal cost there's
all this but the bottom line nasa not
the whole budget nasa's human space
flight budget
okay so for those people less
uh
less economic one-on-one fluent the
marginal cost is the incremental cost
not including the startup costs and the
capital costs that made the thing happen
in the first place correct right so i'm
including those in the billion we're
just putting it all in there so a lot of
people will consider that an unfair
number because they want to use the
marginal cost which is vastly lower but
you have to set the thing up in the
first place right right yeah however
in all fairness to
what people might consider bloat
that is the purpose of a government
um involvement in anything that large
church did i just hear you say in all
fairness to bloat
was that in that sentence i know because
i know that people often get in the
world of fairness yeah i know
because we're saying give blood a chance
blow the chance man
like you know so bloat on
hold on no but my my point is that
people think that the government wastes
money right and that anything that
government is involved in is a waste of
money because the government is doing it
there's a whole point a whole set of
people think that way there's a whole
set of people that just think that and
so but my but what i'm saying is
there are certain things that the
government has to do
because the money
there is no money in it
so it's all waste it's always if it were
private listen so look at me listen to
me right now just follow me here
if you were in 1960 trying to go to the
moon as general electric
that is a complete
waste of money
one hundred percent
waste there is nothing in it for you as
a company there's no profit no there's
no shareholder there's no benefit at all
it's 100 wasted money so when you think
of like the government wasting money
there are many benefits that we got from
going to the moon
it turned out not to be a waste of money
but if you were a corporate ceo that's a
total waste of money okay chuck that is
the first time i've ever heard someone
defend bloat just want to put that out
but second it's 100
an excellent point we don't want people
to think what
nasa is doing should be done by the
private sector the the real difference
here is
nasa the government should be driving
technologies and doing new and exciting
things neil talks about this all the
time like going to the moon
since then perhaps
doing the shuttle program which was
supposed to reduce the cost of taking
people and stuff to and from space it
didn't reduce the cost and so that is
what we're talking about post apollo
yeah very good point okay so it's it's
the bureaucracy it's like the right
stuff form 3612-b
[Laughter]
so so the point is the
um
once we realize that the reusable space
shuttle did not actually make things
cheaper in fact lori correct me if i'm
wrong
even the air force bailed out of the
space shuttle as a launch system for
for
secure
satellites and other activities because
it was too costly and they just launched
it themselves for less do i remember
that correctly
well nasa had
argued successfully that all the defense
military satellites should be on the
shuttle yes in the beginning but after
challenger which you know was our 25th
flight
a new policy said the defense department
military payloads
go elsewhere you know they had to sit
around for years because they were
waiting on the shuttle right the
government was trying
it you know to amortize
um to the credit and to the credit yeah
right
and they ended up
really limiting the shuttle's payloads
after that to only those missions that
required the space shuttle itself and
the volume the volume in the payload
section right well you couldn't just
launch satellites with volume of the
payload because you were risking
astronaut lives at that point so it was
only those those things afterwards that
they there were plenty in the queue who
that had already made themselves
uniquely
capable with with the shuttle so they
didn't move off but for the most part we
built the space station with a space
shuttle after that yeah yeah and so one
last thing before we get to our our uh
patreon questions uh lori i what do what
of the point you know one of the
the clarion calls when someone says uh
you know the government spent you know x
billions of dollars on this and where
does it gotten us and private enterprise
should do it one of the rebuttals is the
money is not in space the money is spent
on earth
and there's thousands of engineers and
scientists who are paid to do this work
from that money on earth that contribute
to their economies and their real estate
and their schools and so
what do you v how do you view that as a
as a legit comeback
to that kind of attack
you know i think when we're spending the
public's money we should always be aware
of
what is the purpose and nasa's purpose
helps us to
improve the economy our national
security and it is an inspiration for
people to
study math and science those were the
original uh i call them fear greed and
glory you have a different take slightly
on that but that's why we do it so to
the extent we are going about
exploring space like we did in apollo
and in the early days with new
technologies the return on that
government investment the return on
those jobs
is a multiplier
what is the problem is when the
government starts just paying us to do
stuff we've already done
and a that competes with the private
sector and b it isn't a multiplier
because you're not
incentivizing sort of
something that yeah is going to have a
bigger a bigger market the launch
industry that we privatize is was so
obviously right for this because we
weren't launching any
satellites anymore commercially because
we had priced ourselves out with a
shuttle and the u.s rockets were being
run by a monopoly united launch alliance
so
we really have now come back against
china russia and the french who were
launching all the satellites and now
that's huge for our economy so those
those investments were job multipliers
wait so lori here's an interesting uh
dimension here throughout all of gemini
apollo
uh mercury gemini apollo
we have contracted with the space
industrial complex but their names are
not on any of the vessels
okay you didn't see lockheed martin
boeing they're not on any of the vessels
so it looked like
we nasa just did it all themselves but
that wasn't the case whereas now with
pure private industry it says spacex
going up no
no bout to doubt it right so
um is there any reason for that shift
yes the it is fascinating to me that the
companies themselves who have been
building this stuff for years they
didn't get their names on them and i
don't know if they ever asked but they
do advertise
uh with those programs constantly and so
you'll see their logo tied in with
programs but what the difference is now
primarily with spacex is they are
putting their own skin in the game that
when they've got a program the way nasa
is now contracting spacex sort of owns
it and nasa's just buying a service so
when i was at nasa in around 2012 they
were launching to the space station for
the first time spacex asked if they
could put nasa's name on the rocket oh
wow wow guess what nasa said no no
not our rocket
and poor gwen shot welshes she is still
the president called i i thought i could
break that free but the head of nasa
wasn't interested in doing that the
lawyers gave them some you know
it's not a rocket well
i was shocked when before a commercial
crew they come out not only as the
rocket phil's logos of nasa and spacex
what they drove out there in tesla cars
yes i mean
the fact that nasa has embraced this
program um who
initially one of their arguments for not
doing it was the public won't pay
attention if it's not nasa
i mean we just couldn't have gotten it
more wrong in some ways yeah but they're
doing a good job uh i guess i mean it's
a little
it's it's more than even i would have
probably done yeah
and i i think it's funny because when
you say the public don't pay attention
because it's not if it's not nasa
it's like there's one car service that
takes people to
the theater or the movie or a concert
and everybody thinks that
people are actually concerned about the
car service you know
it's like no the car service only takes
you to the main show space is the main
show
what are you doing in space and who
you're launching right right nasa
probably would have never launched 90
year old will shatner they would have
seen it as a stunt
and you look at the media attention that
god
uh so there's a certain sort of cultural
well you know nasa probably shouldn't
have launched
william shatner
you know i mean would you want your tax
dollars going to that i don't know
i don't think so we are
the comedians own something because you
all imitate them all the time well
that's what i was going to say what was
fascinating
10 of every gig that you did did it in
you know when he returned he was more
eloquent than anyone i've i've ever
heard he was clearly moved by the
experience i will say that you're right
about that
um
my i will say my favorite memory of all
of these launches
was seeing him step off of the the the
vessel
and talk about the emotional
connection that he now had to you know
what just happened and just for what
it's worth uh astronauts at least
historically were not selected based on
how emotional they are
dude this is amazing i can't believe
what i'm saying oh my god what is that
red light what's that red light hello
what we're going to do oh my gosh
it was the george costanza rule that was
the opposite they wanted to be cool
houston we have a problem right yeah
so lori we're going to take a quick
break when we come back we're going to
hit our patreon questions who that
they're raring to go here and chuck you
got the list i do all right all right
when we come back more with a friend and
and and long-time co-worker when i was
sort of had a lot of overlap with the
space um industry and with nasa itself
lori garver we'll be right back
we're back
star talk cosmic queries edition and
this one
is all about the transition of nasa and
just the world in its acceptance of
commercial space relative to
space programs so it's civil space i
guess that was called and so lori you've
just written a book and i happen to know
this book was going to have a different
title what title did you originally
propose it at
well i proposed originally as
billionaires and bureaucrats the race to
save nasa uh the publishers changed it
to space pirates which is how i refer to
the community of people in the space
movement we like to think we have a
movement i'm not sure we do but we like
to and um
they've eventually changed it to
escaping gravity which is also a
pleasant title i have no problem with
that yeah yeah it was just not uniquely
that book because any book on space can
yeah
i had i had to reformat it a bit but i
liked it too they did their their
research on it and that's what they came
up with i think billionaires and
bureaucrats was
very early on you know
although i've been involved in a lot of
different aspects of nasa as you said
that has tended to be the flash point in
my career i was a bureaucrat and i was
supporting doing this
uh with the billionaires i actually
think you need both so the answer is
very clear it's not a bursus
just to be clear i think you need one a
little bit more than
i'm just gonna say
all right yeah i'm just
i know i'm i know i'm somebody who just
defended bloat and i'm about to defend
beerus
but uh yeah billionaires don't add uh to
the public good as much as bureaucrats
do i mean this is good bureaucrats but
you need the money at some point so
right oh yeah you're right but you know
what's funny is we say bureaucrats but
what i call them are
um
career government officials yeah but
chuck you have never heard bureaucrat in
a sentence that was positive that's my
brain
but then you look at people like let's
just say take for instance a solicitor
general
that's a bureaucrat but that's somebody
who has a very important
um
position in the government you know
no one
yes truck but no one will call him a
bureaucrat because the bureaucrat is an
insult
but it shouldn't be i don't think it
should be either i agree i'm just
telling you not don't don't shoot the
messenger i think we
my point is i do think neil and i would
agree with with chuck and that this is
really
um good people for the most part yes
doing work on behalf of the public and
nasa's one of those great agencies doing
that now did i talk about and book some
of the
individuals and things going on that
shouldn't be yes and that's partly
because i believe it's such an important
thing that we need to be doing as
government and when we can't share with
the public that what we're doing is all
above board and efficient
we have problems and so i think
billionaires weren't
were not even part of what we were
thinking of in the 1990s when we were
looking to
more involve private sector and
launching rockets uh we didn't have
people worth the amount of billions that
we do now and it was not even a
consideration lockheed martin won the
first effort to privatize sort of the
post shuttle space transportation it
didn't end up
working for technical reasons probably
some business reasons as well because we
had at that point the constellations of
satellites that were predicted to be
launching
uh
ended up being
hopefully well now delayed rather than
cancelled by the bursting of the dot-com
bubble back at the in the day yes yes
yes forgot about that duck i know
they're right right there were companies
trying to do exactly what
spacex uh and blue origin and virgin
ended up doing
in the 90s but they lost their shirts
because they didn't end up having stuff
to launch well this is this is elon
musk's famous quote uh how do you make a
small fortune in the space industry
start with a large fortune
[Applause]
yeah
so lori the book uh is out now people
can buy it at a at a your favorite uh
book outlet whatever that might be and
chuck you got questions for us yes we do
let's let's jump right into it here we
go
this is lucas charleston
he says do you think of private
companies
do go into space exploration
will it prompt competition that will
speed up
technologies that will cause more
companies to go into space exploration
yes uh and where would their
funding come from now there's the rug
that's the road see i don't know here's
the rub i might disagree with lori on
this one we'll hear your your answer
first
i think it is already happening um i
think the earlier companies that did
this drove technologies that have made
their their way into
other um either parts of the satellites
to reduce the cost and the mass because
a lot of this is about
launching smaller things cost less um
and now that that capability is
expanding although
a lot of these are protected i.p rights
you do end up having more and more
companies i think there's over a hundred
uh startup launch companies right now
they're not all going to make it but
they are all adding their own unique
innovation and the people who are doing
it were trained
from you know working for the previous
companies
yeah and ip is intellectual property
right yeah as you use that abbreviation
so what you're saying there i hadn't
really thought about this the total
number of startup companies you only
exist as a startup because you're coming
to the table with something nobody else
has some niche that you hope grows to
become large but the fact that you're at
the table at all
the sum of the startup companies
represents a remarkable moving frontier
of science and technology
is that fair statement yes and much of
that does make its way into consumer
products these are things that really
it's a virtuous cycle
what used to be um it cost so much
because everything was so expensive that
end up
being its own
negative feedback cycle but now you're
seeing people oh well it doesn't cost
that much to launch so i can try this
out yeah and then things work and then
they're gonna oh well maybe we could
refuel on orbit maybe we could do these
other things things that have been on
nasa's plate for a long time but frankly
nasa became a little calcified and risk
uh you know scared of risk mainly
because
the political establishment in congress
and some administrations didn't want to
see anything fail
more of your frenemies
scattered around the government so so
but
getting back to that other important
point of that question and this is where
we might part ways laurie
uh
people use the word exploration as
though anyone going into space is
exploring but when i think of
exploration i think advancing a space
frontier going farther
onto objects that have never been
previously explored exploited i do not
see a business model for that and so i
see nasa as this as a uniquely capable
of posing questions and answering
questions that would later on that hand
it over to industry once they figure out
the sources of risk
for it and i have agreed with you on
this point for a long time the only
difference being these billionaires
they are out there they don't have to
satisfy a shareholder uh they they can
just do it and once they have the real
question
to what you said is at what price point
is there not a market and if they can do
something that lowers that price point
enough but then it does make sense
there there might be more business cases
but i i don't see many beyond
tourism at this point right got it got
it okay all right keep going oh that
brings us to what a perfect subway to of
nish yoshi or joshi who says this hello
dr tyson and deputy garber i'm avnish
i'm 11 years old
i heard about an asteroid in the
asteroid belt called sixteen psych i
also heard there was a mission being
sent out with the objective to mine that
asteroid and to make sure that it was a
planet core first of all is this true
secondly when will that happen and third
what technology will we use
also
dovetailing onto what you guys just said
will nasa continue to do this kind of
research
when commercial
organizations take over space
exploration
the child is out how does the 11 year
old really say that
okay so now and he says i'm uh i'm from
i'm avnish uh from houston texas texas
and then uh it says this totally was not
written by his father
uh
but also i was gonna say nasa yeah i was
going to say who uh what's he got going
in his basement but in in houston they
don't have basements so it would have to
be in his garage to see what he's
working on that nobody knows about well
asteroids and the sighting mission those
are and the overall question is so
important and i would tell you by the
way it's named after the the
greek uh mythological character psyche
so
you pronounce the e at the end like
penelope psyche right
so
that asteroid if i remember correctly
represents a planet that had mostly
formed and it was broken apart but if
you have a mostly foreign planet all the
heavy stuff falls to the middle and the
lighter stuff floats to the top we have
an explainer um uh video on that
and so if what what is heavy that would
fall to the middle uh palladium gold
silver platinum iron
cha-ching baby octopus
except for the iron chain yeah so you
would hand pick your asteroids that have
been pre-sifted to be rich in these
elements that you might
care about more than other elements now
lori go for it
yeah that is a great background for my
my points about the value of not just
the psyche mission but the asteroid
search
is
asteroids for three primary reasons are
areas that we as humanity care about one
is what neil just talked about and this
is a particularly
um hopefully rich asteroid and for any
kind of future space development people
feel we will need to use the resources
of asteroids probably never going to you
know mine the gold and send it back it's
never going to
get cheap enough to do that that it's
worth it but utilizing those for space
development those materials is really
important for a future and just to be
clear that's how the movie
don't look up ended
okay someone came in and said don't blow
this out of the sky
let's mine it for its resources
and
and by the way that guy was a
billionaire in the movie
yes he was gone
hilariously silly movie but the um the
second reason there okay they can hit us
obviously this is something that we have
around this experiment people know that
dinosaurs didn't make it because they
didn't have a space program
um nasa has a role i won't say they're
the lead role because there's a lot of
questions about that but diverting a
potential
uh
planet hurting or killing asteroid is
something that we need to care about so
we need to understand
asteroids better track them to see when
they're coming and figure out ways to
move them if needed
just to add to it just to add to lori's
point it's not to know to understand an
asteroid this isn't a psychological
session tell me about yourself esther
it's that physically
many asteroids we do not know what's
holding them together and are they piles
of rock are they solid are the two
pieces stuck together and so if you
should go up and try to push it you want
to know full well in advance how it's
going to respond to how you touch it
otherwise your whole mission could fail
so when laurie says casually yes we want
to understand the asteroid it is
uh there's a lot behind that one a lot
of meaning there yeah i like i like the
the the more understood meaning better
it's just you know how do you feel
so the third is we
believe that life uh very likely
transform transferred here
in a commoner asteroid so they may hold
the seeds to life so comets and
asteroids are incredibly important and
therefore
to the point of the
question
we need to be studying them and the
government in my view has an important
role in doing that now to the extent the
private sector should this is a the
perfect way you could transition the
government does a mission like psyche
we're about the first mission the first
mission yeah first mission able to
characterize the asteroid able to help
determine ways that it could potentially
be moved and how when we see the
signature of asteroids
uh coming toward us
what that might mean they look like
close up there's a lot of science that
will go into this
but when we have that information you
can imagine certain industries having
more interest in
going to the asteroids in the future
that have heavy metals and the things
that they'll want to study we're going
to take a quick quick break
and lori when we come back once you
start off telling us about uh space
resources is that what they're called
there's a startup
company or organization
that wants to be the first to mine
asteroids so when when start talk
cosmic queries continues
nice little bit of
alliteration there we've got lori garver
old time friend and space professional
when we come back
lori we left off with a question from an
11 year old
who lives in
texas so he doesn't really have a
basement probably so i wonder if his
parents know what he's making in the
garage
okay is he uh he's got a cloaking device
so you can't they couldn't know even
they have no idea
so
uh so lori this notion that we would uh
nasa would have a mission to the
asteroid psyche which would be rich in
the kind of materials that would sink to
the middle of a planet and this is an
asteroid left over from a shattered
planet
uh what
i i heard that there's some companies
today
that have prioritized
mining asteroids for just that purpose i
mean can you comment on any of them
sure you know there have been companies
looking at this for decades and mining
the moon is probably a first
uh order that's an easy target yeah yeah
the government is going to start with
the whole reason we haven't talked about
artemis yet but the whole reason to send
people back to the moon this time is to
land at the south pole near where you
could mine resources namely water that
might be trapped in the ice in the
shaded parts of the south pole of the
moon those music might be chuck there
are places in the south pole where the
rim of the crater
permanently prevents sun from reaching
the crater because the sun doesn't get
very high in the sky okay okay so
literally we're looking for water where
the sun don't shine
you know that just does not sound the
con it's certainly not potable
certainly not potable that's all i'm
saying all those astronauts drink
they're on your own so i'm pretty sure
and like sweat right and the moisture
that that they evaporates from their
skin yeah it's pretty nasty very doom
it's very very difficult we're going to
all be there so these are technologies
that we might want to see be uh
perfected it's all doomed okay so go on
laurie interrupted uh so mining
asteroids mining the moon is something
that companies are starting to look at
seriously and i i think the business
plans will be long term i think the
technologies will be driven by the
government another great example of how
this sort of hand and glove
um
situation can help us
advance space development and
potentially exploration and if you're
good at getting around asteroids you
know tell the mining company oh by the
way that one of those is headed towards
us could you deflect it over to the left
a little they'll probably have the
ability and the resources to do that and
i'm just waiting for the space force to
step up and say that it's their job i've
been up in their face about it ever
since they were birthed so okay what's
their reaction
uh nods uh i don't think that was their
original intent right they weren't
thinking that way but
this was an issue for us for us at nasa
is we would have the expertise but then
the military and in that point mainly
the air force will come and say oh yeah
we're the guardians of the galaxy it's
like well
the air force fully contained everything
space in the pentagon
before we had the space force so that
that's what you're saying there yeah
okay chuck give me another one
all right here we go
and authorities keep an eye on that kid
we don't want him to
please
exactly
what superhero nemesis is he going to be
i don't know abness is
his i'm puberty man
is this something that's where we're
gonna look at what superhero doesn't
have a nemesis yet we'll line him up for
that okay
so go on okay
um this is from alexander newhouse who
says um
uh deputy garver uh what is the current
state of space
law
as it relates to public and private
missions going to outer space in fact
let me tighten that and say what is the
state of space law related to who owns
what
all right do i own the asteroid that i
mine right right right if i pitch tent
on mars do i own the the acre of land
around it so where does all that sit
right now
it is a work in progress that one of the
big challenges and this is pretty
typical throughout history a technology
advances to a point where oh we don't
have the governance set up correctly to
manage this um and that's really where
we are in space we started in the 60s
with
uh
the outer space treaty which said that
celestial bodies cannot be privately
owned and by
signing that
uh the u.s as a space faring nation did
not claim the moon you noticed when we
landed in spite of putting the flag
there which is what anyone does when
they're claiming something sadly yeah
yeah listen this is for us all it's like
it's like an oscar i'm accepting this on
behalf of everyone who was nominated i
mean i'm taking it home
it's gonna be my mantle not yours yeah
and and those moon rocks in the not
basement in houston texas and johnson
space center uh
are are every once but just try to try
to get a little piece one find out nasa
they're nasa's um but we really have um
a lot of progress made space lawyers
have been working on all kinds of
activities but in my mind the big issue
of rights claims is not settled and one
of the things that companies who want to
go and do the mining of the asteroids
want is to be able to claim if we can
get there we
it can be ours and we can make money off
of it so that's the whole it's a
homesteading market basically yeah yeah
and and the space pirates really believe
this because that's sort of why i name
them the space pirates they really
believe that it should be
people going out and doing this like the
frontier in the united states
um
we had you know the ability to just have
the
you could work the land you could own
the land the 1800s 1800s united states
was all about that right and that is the
kind of thing they like to model um in
in outer space but we are a long ways
from that
i'm going to say a problematic
historical period to uh base any model
no we aren't unaware of any native
people out or even organisms out there
but that doesn't mean they're not there
and our history is replete with yes
these nuts plus nasa i think has all but
completely removed the word colonization
from their official documents i i think
frontier is even
even that yeah
no more yeah not even frontier huh right
right right
it's not called a man spacer it's called
crude c or e well and when you said you
know everyone we put our flag on the
moon we did it from mankind so that's
why we've got one artist that was early
enough so that no one knew how to
otherwise say it oh no
i didn't feel i didn't feel the warmth
you didn't feel it
okay
nope you were feeling it not until
valentina you weren't feeling it
yeah that's great
okay tell chuck who valentina is because
he doesn't know first woman in space
yeah russian
russian and it took the us 20 years
after her
to have our first sally ryan
ride sally ride was the headline
yeah
first small small text american woman in
space right yeah yeah yeah yeah
rather than the headline after 20
freaking years we finally get around to
having a female astronaut so chuck let's
do a lightning round okay
can we knock it actually it's not enough
to chuck it's up to laurie okay we're
gonna do a lightning round okay
we'll we'll see how your sound bites
work okay we didn't do too bad with
these with the ones that we have so yeah
okay
yeah um here we go um
this is chris hampton he says hey i'm
currently 25 years old
do you think that by the time
i am in my 80s that i will be able to
take a sightseeing trip
to jupiter or
saturn or at least just see those
planets as i go around them
even if it's a one-way trip
let me lead off by saying that's why we
invented telescopes
yeah how far away do you want to be
all right so lori uh humans to the out
beyond the asteroid belt that's really
what that question is what do you think
maybe it would take leaps you know we
always judge our near future we think we
can do more in it than than we can but
in the far future we tend to misjudge
for the opposite reason correct correct
so i don't want to roll i would i
wouldn't rule it out but you don't have
the technology
55 years in the future yeah yeah
not today we don't have the technology
okay let me ask you both it sounds like
what's the biggest impediment for
uh doing something like that so humans
ability to survive the radiation because
our propulsive
methods are slow right yeah so it's a
combination so if you could go a lot
faster you might be able to survive
right you get there and back and not get
heavily irradiated but plus you got it
ready to you know invest you know saturn
is twice as far away as jupiter so
you know jupiter is is it a five-year
trip six years and saturn are you ready
to give up that big a fraction of your
life to see what you might be able to
see through a telescope or better yet to
see what a space an orbiting space probe
will do we'll see those pictures from
cassini really great pictures yeah oh my
gosh yeah so that's the uh the real
question is so why you know why would
you want to and that's a big big
question so nasa should sell picture
frame windows
with extra 8k video of their space
missions and make people think that
they're actually on this craft itself
listen that would work i mean i see it
as as a ride at disney that's very
popular yep you know but uh you're right
why i i mean listen i think it would be
great
to lay eyes on
you know any part of antarctica
okay but guess what i don't i'm i don't
know unless i can walk i'm not going
okay
so now you're gonna get me because i
have done it and it was a little bit of
a junket
government blow situation but i was
checking out antarctica as a government
employee and
i don't know it's not the same if you're
not there oh you've got to be there
you're just making his point now i
totally am you're totally making this
video it's gonna just look out a window
and when the plane the massive you know
cargo plane lands at 12 000 feet on the
pole because
it's mountainous region
flat only because it's all filled on
with glacier okay wait just to be clear
lori that's not happening on any planet
or any moon in the solar system i know
he's not disembarking from the space
ship
that is that yeah that's kind of an
important difference here well it would
be the equivalent but for chug uh you
get the chance to go to antarctica
i wouldn't rule it out should do it okay
all right
but wait wait lori have you noticed his
skin color okay i was gonna say you i
was just about to say laura you would
not find a frozen black man anywhere on
this planet
if they thought the caveman out of the
glacier that would not be a black people
there was not one
caveman
named
[Laughter]
all right no no no we're done here we
don't have any more time oh we don't
have time okay oh man oh man that was
super fun well i don't know why we
haven't had john before because you
would have been either oh mike you had
such a trove of insight it's so
interesting when when she asked me
they're publishing i'm like yeah
i don't think
yeah yeah no we that's an oversight and
i'm embarrassed by that because that's
okay you were totally in the middle of
all that as it was going down and so now
you could be like our as they do on the
news their expert commentator who used
to be in it and now they observe it and
then comment all those sports stars yeah
exactly exactly so that's maybe we'll
have to connect you in that way going
forward but good luck with the book um
like i said it's a front row seat and
please remind us of the name
escaping gravity
my quest to
transform nasa and launch a new space
age nice which is precisely what we are
in the middle of thanks to your help in
spite of all the enemies you made along
the way and chuck she's very candid
about who became a friend and who became
an enemy simply because of the world
views that they carried forward and
that's a bit of candor you don't
typically see so thanks for that gift
i'll call it a gift lori of your life
story to the rest of us laurie are you
on social media
yes i am well how do we find you twitter
laurie underscore garber and laurie with
an i yes yes l-o-r-i underscore
g-a-r-v-e-r
okay excellent and chuck always there at
chuck nice comic yes sir thank you you
got it all right this has been star talk
cosmic queries space program edition
space program becoming space industry
edition
neil degrasse tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Music]